hello everyone and welcome to game
number 10 of the 2013 World Chess
Championship match between Viswanathan
Anand and the Magnus Carlsen I as you've
seen in my previous nine videos from
this match Carson is now three points in
the leader the result is six to three
and if Anand wants to continue playing
this match he has to win all of the next
three games in a row to equalize the
score so it was definitely a tough blow
for Anand in game nine as you've seen he
found that beautiful move look to a four
but he missed Coulson's idea of Queenie
one and then you know he immediately had
to resign the game as there was nothing
to look for anymore but even that game
as Anand says was not such a terrible
blow as the one he faced in Game five
but before we check out the game we do
have a quick photo challenge for this
video and it's it's really a difficult
one so I will give you one hint as I
don't think I don't think it will be
possible to solve this one without a
hint so here it is who is the person
that is still in the train so not not
the gentleman outside of the Train but
the person inside the train behind Mrs n
so I'm not gonna tell you who it is but
I will give you a hint there is a
certain line of the Sicilian defense
named after him you know that's pretty
famous one at that so best of luck to
everyone now let's check out the game
Anand is now playing with the black
pieces and out of the next three games
he will have the black pieces twice and
only once will he have the white pieces
and if he doesn't win this game then the
match is instantly over as Coulson
already has six and a half points so
let's see what Anand plays when he has
to win the game course and opens with E
4 and here Allen goes for c5 so now we
have the Sicilian defense here you can
see that you know when you need to win
play the Sicilian Knight to f3 d6 and
here Carlsen doesn't go for the standard
d4 rather he goes for Bishop to b5 and
the canal attack this comes with 2 check
and Anand blocks up with Knight to d7
Bishop to d7 is also possible but Anand
already tried this against
in 2012 in Bilbao and the Colson won
that game so nice to be seven here d4c
capture Sundy for Queen captures on d4
and a6 attacking the bishop I think we
have a photo from this game okay it's
not not dispositive maybe it is
disposition the bishop is Anna the
bishop the bishop moved so it's not
really that position but I think it
could be yeah I have no idea
oh yeah that's a pawn okay so it's a
position that will happen a few moves
down but you know just to get in the
mood so a six but should capture some d7
but should capture some d7 and now C for
a Knight to c3 is also possible it's the
sharpest variation but Rossum wants to
keep everything solid he did he did give
up the bishop repair but he has a very
nice center and a firm grip on the d5
square we have Knight to f6 also here a
nice sharp variation is he five but
Anand and Carson already played this
variation in Sunday's in 2013 and on and
couldn't achieve anything in that
variation so if he wants to win he has
to try something different
so Knight to f6 we had a Bishop to g5 e
six Knight to c3
we have Bishop to e7 castles and Bishop
the c6 now Queen back to d3 and unearned
castles 9th to d4 now a cross and goes
for the light square Bishop rook to c8
and now b3 we have Queen to the c7 now
Knight captures we have Queen captures
and the rook to see one every exchange
that happens on the board definitely
goes Carson's way as he does have the
white pieces he only needs a draw to
become world champion so simply just you
know keeping everything solid h6 now
Bishop to e3
Knight to d7 and now Bishop to Bishop to
d4 rook F to d8 we have a ch3 Queen to
c7 and now rook F to D one Queen to a5
and now Queen to d2 preparing either to
trade Queens but also the Queen now
gives further protection to the a to
pawn
here we have King 2f8 Bishop to g5 is
possible but the Bishop to g5 can be met
with f4 but also Bishop to e3 works very
nicely after a bunch of characters our
queen characters tonight is coming to e5
and this is perfectly fine for black but
it's it's not gonna give you any
advantages and you can't really afford
to trade pieces you're not gonna win the
game by trading pieces so after Queen d2
we have a king to f8 now cross in place
Queen to b2 and here a very interesting
moment Anand repeats the position King
to g8 it seems that it seems that we she
has given up in an attempt to actually
win this game and he allows cause and to
also repeat the position and who knows
maybe he's just testing Carlsen or maybe
he really would repeat the position for
the third time but here we have a very
interesting moment Coulson actually
doesn't repeat the position even though
he only needs a draw to win this match
he plays a4 and he continues the fight
Queen to h5 we have Knight to e2 Bishop
to f6 and here comes Rock the c3 a nice
rook lift now the the rook will also
help out with the defense of the pieces
and the pawns in the center we have
Bishop captures rook captures and Queen
to e5 now Queen to d2
now comes Knight to f6 and now rook to
e3 and now Carson's rooks are very
awkwardly placed here this rook is very
not very active you know it has to stay
here to keep an eye on d4 pawn and also
this rook has to stay here to keep an
eye on the e4 pawn so not not the
greatest activity out of the these
groups but Ahrens rooks aren't also so
active so rook to d7 we have a 5 now
locking those pawns on the on the Queen
side and here
Anand makes island makes a blunder he
plays Queen to g5 and here Carlsen
immediately takes advantage of this he
plays d5 now of course you cannot
capture the pawn as your rook on the on
d7 is hanging so nice to e8 only move
and now Carlson place he captures on d6
this is releasing the tension too soon
here cousin
could have gone a good could have kept
the tension and maybe even played this
game out for a win by Knight to c3 and
then the knight is also coming in to
attack the Queen and also to pile up on
the d6 pawn but Carson decided for to
play each chapters on d6 may not
probably not because he didn't see how
to improve the tension maybe because he
now realized that you know I only need a
row I don't I don't really need to win
this game so look to c6 now further they
are piling up on the d6 pawn we have F
for attacking the Queen Queen to d8 and
now rope to d3 and here there really is
nothing better you simply do have to
grab the pawn so rook captures rook
captures rook captures rook captures
Queen captures Queen captures and Knight
captures and now you can see that the
material is completely equal on the
board both players have to pawn islands
but Causton does have three to two
advantage on the Queen side and okay for
those of you who are new to chests you
might say okay but on earth has four to
three advantage on the King side but the
advantage isn't so important because
there are also kings here so four pawns
and the King will will not be able to
push against three points and the King
about three points against two points
without Kings that's a very nice
advantage so King to f2 of course you
have to bring your King into the game
acting to f8 King III King II 7 into d4
came to d7 King to c5 now King to c7
Knight to c3
we have Knight to f5 93 4/9 to e3 and
now G 3 we have f5 and now Knight to d6
9th to d2 was also possible simply
keeping an eye on everything but Carlson
has health Carson has a very nice idea
he plays Knight to d6 g5 comes and not
nice to e 8 with check we have King King
to d7
not Knight to f6 with check King to e7
and now Knight the g8 with check King to
f8 and now we have Knight characters on
h6g captures an F for G characters on f4
and now King to g7 and
seems cousins the night is trapped and
the night has nowhere to go and of
course that is true but this was all
part of Carlson's plan night captures on
f5 was played we have a captors on f5 if
you play night characters and i-5 then
the night is too far away from the
queenside and then white will even win
this game because he simply eliminates
these pawns and then three passports are
I will be winning
so here Knight captures on f5 and now
King Tubby six sorry I meant he captures
on i-5 and now coming to b6 going after
the Queen side pawns now comes Knight g2
King capture some b7 and Knight captures
on i-4 we have King characters on a six
and now nice to the nine three six King
Tubby six we have F for a six f3 both
players are going are pushing their past
pawn a 7f two across and brings the
Queen into the game Anand also brings a
queen into the game Queen to d5
attacking the knight now Queen to e1
defending and now Queen to d6 it's a
it's a very complicated position because
there are 3-3 passed pawns against a
knight but you know the Kings are on an
open board there's really no way for
each side to make progress the other
side will always be able to do something
about it so we need to recheck King
moves now comes nice to see for chassis
5 check
but since Ireland does have a knight you
know it's always possible that something
can happen Knights are Knights are
tricky
King to the king to b5 and night capture
some b3 now Queen checks King moves
Queen b6 now forcing a trade of Queens
we have Queen character skin captures
and now you can see that no longer can
can and win the game as he only has a
knight so we have King to h5 now comes
h4 King captures on h4 c5 and cross and
even pushes it all the way we have
Knight captures on c5 and it was in this
position that the players agreed to a
draw oh I mean it's a it's a draw by
insufficient material I believe that's
the the correct term but you know again
they draw
in a position where Carlson could have
captured the night you know and leave
nicely leave the Kings and the board but
they decided to leave it this way so
yeah that's that's game ten and since
Aaron was unable to win game ten that
means that the 2013 World Chess
Championship is over Magnus Carlsen won
the World Chess Championship title and
he is now the new world chess champion
and he still the new world chess
champion ever since he took the title
away from vishwanatham Island so yeah
that was the game I do hope you enjoyed
it and I do hope you enjoyed this entire
coverage you know I do have to say that
I really enjoyed it myself because
really researching about what's happened
you know before every game at every game
you know even even the little things
what players ate during the games you
know pretty much everything really
really I feel that you know it helped
improve my vast knowledge and hopefully
hopefully yours do so yeah I'm gonna
figure out what to do next probably
gonna you know just relax a bit figure
out maybe do some of your suggestions
and maybe do a nice mini series about
something and then before starting the
next big series I think we'll do we'll
do voting again and then you know
whatever you prefer them that's that's
where we'll go either visit some old
classics you know it visit kappa blanka
and I can either bobby fischer or you
know we can even just continue with the
2014 candidates tournament and then you
know and so on and so on but yeah you
know there are countless possibilities
so I will definitely you know ask you
for your advice and like we've said I'm
still still taking suggestions what do
you want from her for the 2000
subscribers a 200,000 subscribers stream
so feel free to suggest that as well and
you know if you have any interesting
game to suggest them now as I I might
even leave my home town for the weekend
so I'm gonna have to prepare something
while I'm away
so yeah I would like to thank Stephen
green James Graham Stuart's newly guru
assuage and the rain
even for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully with some
some new interesting and you know vast
knowledge improving the videos so yeah
and yeah let's I did prepare some photos
here so as you know after you know
Carlson was very happy and you're
welcome to check out the press
conference after game ten I will also
put a link to it in the description
below but then after everything was over
then they threw call across and in the
pool this is a nice photo you can see
that Ireland isn't too too unhappy of
course you are unhappy just was the
World Chess Championship title but you
know he did congratulate Carlsen and he
did say that you know it was totally
deserving and you know that that he
definitely dominated the entire match
after after that game five everything
just went downhill for Ireland but yeah
then after all was said and done after
the press conference
they threw Magnus Carlsen in the pool
and here there is even a video available
of this moment you can find it easily
online here let's just check out one
more from the pool and yeah that's it
that's it for this world chess
championship series once again thank you
all and I will see you soon with some
hopefully interesting content see you
soon